لا شيء يعكر صفو الحياه هنا في وضعها
الطبيعي غير ان سعي السكاني للبحث عن سبل
العيش الكريم يحوز غالب اهتمامهم الحاج
خالد مزارع في منطقه تنجازي احدى القرى
المحاذيه لمحيط مطار مروه
ما حصل يوم من الايام نحن سمعناه لا
تتوضعناه ولا غنابل المشاكل حصلت يعني
فجاه انا اصبحت مروعه يا اخواننا يعني شيل
الحصر ده حصل رجّ البلد الناس خافت
المواطنين
الطبيعه ترسم لوحه زاهيه في قريه ينشط
اهلها في ممارسه الزراعه بين انهم تعرضوا
لتهديد استقرارهم وفقدوا امنهم لعده ايام
نحن من خلقنا بيوتنا دي مفتحه لحد الصباح
ما قعدنا اقفل بابات الحيش يا
وضمان وامان ومرتاحين راحه كامله ما
متوقعه زي دي تحصل
كانت عندنا يعني الشغله دي والله زي رايته
يعني نحن الحمد لله
ايام من الرعب عاشها سكان القرى المتاخمه
لمطار مروى الدولي بسبب القتال بين قوات
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ويحاول الناس
تجاوز ما يعتبرونه تجربه قاسيه هي الاولى
من نوعها في المنطقه خصوصا انها جاءت في
الايام الاخيره من شهر رمضان وقبل عيد
الفطر المبارك بوقت قصير
يحاول مواطن منطقه مروي وما جاورها في
شمال السودان مغالبه ظروف استثنائيه نالت
تاثيراتها تفاصيل حياتهم نتيجه المواجهات
العسكريه التي استمرت لايام لكن للعيد
فرحه خاصه وربما يمثل فرصه للخروج من
اظابير حزن طارق الحمد لله البلد في امان
الوضع مستغير الاسواق فتحا وهنا سواقنا ما
شاء الله دايرين لنا الحمد لله
ما في مشكله الحمد لله
كانت هذه السوق مغلقه لعده ايام بسبب
انعدام الامن وتطورات المواجهات المسلحه
غير ان الحياه بدات تدب تدريجيا في
المدينه بعد اعلان الجيش احكام سيطرته على
مطار مروى والقاعده العسكريه الملحقه به
اسامه سيدي احمد الجزيره من منطقه مروي
شمالي السودان